I want to bring back in congressman
meadows congressman when you see this
out there these are people of Minnesota
that are police officers they're
attacking people that their own
neighbors and friends and loved ones but
what's your reaction to this well what a
difference
twenty minutes makes you know inside the
arena just a few minutes ago was really
lifting up and honoring the law
enforcement and in giving them the
respect that they're due and yet outside
a few minutes later you have just it
appears to be just hostility towards law
enforcement and really an unruly crowd
listen this is all about making sure
that they can try to intimidate future
Trump rally supporters and goers and
that's just not going to happen Jason
you've seen this time and time again
you've covered it we need to make sure
that we respect our law enforcement and
those that are seeking to keep people
safe you know freedom of expression does
not mean that you can turn to violence
to to accommodate your cause no and this
is I think going to be a major theme in
the election Donald Trump has taken a
position that's very Pro law enforcement
certainly as you look at ice and
immigration issues out there you see the
Democrats want to abolish ice they
certainly have been supportive of them
they have been calling them all kinds of
names across the way but I got to tell
you I think you're gonna see this I mean
this election is still more than a year
away and you're seeing what kind of
violence will want to break out for
people who tried to express their First
Amendment rights the mayor in this
situation certainly didn't happen what
was your reaction when you heard what
the mayor was saying about the Trump
spending visit well the mayor was a
unbelievable partisan instead of a
public servant and and when you look at
at him trying to charge for security
detail far and above what previous
events have been charged you know I
think it just the American people see it
for what it is it's you know a city
mayor that didn't vote for this
president or probably didn't vote for
this president and certainly not
supportive of him trying to make a
political point
instead of serving the public not only
there in Minneapolis but we we see that
across the country so what we need to
make sure of is we take that message of
freedom and hope to all Americans from
coast to coast from from Maine to
Florida and from New York to California
and in between and that we show them the
difference you know the vast majority of
America respects law enforcement
appreciates the rule of law and do not
endorse lawlessness well and I think
this is gonna be one of the issues I
think what they're trying to do is
suppress people from coming out they're
trying to embarrass people make them
feel shameful for coming out and
supporting Trump in numbers but I got to
tell you the people that I know in the
Midwest and across this country aren't
going to be shut down by a bunch of
antifoam members and some other hoodlums
who would be out there and trying to
suppress the basic human right of
participating in an election and being
able to express themselves congressman I
got I got one other thing I've gotta
shift gears a little bit about the
whistle blower there's a discussion now
about whether or not this so called the
whistle blower I don't know if you can
use that term accurately but as a
whistle blower should this person have
to testify in person or should they do
what is being considered which is allow
them to just testify based on written
questions now listen Jason you have
experience with this you were the
chairman of the Oversight Committee and
you had jurisdiction over whistleblowers
and that whistleblower protection the
reason why there's a statute is so when
they become public that they don't get
retaliated against you know to have an
anonymous ask questions via written
correspondence it's just not what our
government is set up to do
if the whistleblower wants to come
forward they need to be identified they
need to have protection but at the same
time they need to be cross-examined to
see what their motivation you know we're
learning tonight that there's
particularly a bias potentially a bias
from a partisan standpoint so we we need
to make sure we hear directly from them
all right let's go back and talk about I
don't know congressman if you've had the
feedback to be able to see these
pictures that we're able to see here on
camera but what we haven't seen yet are
the Trump supporters coming out of the
building you have the cameras they're
showing protesters you see people and
masked people can wear masks if they
want but they don't seem to be hey
friendly welcome to Minneapolis
certainly the police don't feel that way
I don't know if you can see what's
happening here but what's your reaction
when you when these pictures come across
well listen it's not the Welcome Wagon
for sure and as you see that listen when
we have this kind of activity in this
kind of hostile activity it's really not
what our country was founded upon it was
you know the freedom to express
ourselves we need to make sure that we
do that but we need to do it in a civil
manner that's not what we're seeing work
out on the streets of Minneapolis
tonight congressman thank you so much
for bearing with us we appreciate your
thoughts